all right well temperatures are rising
in with the three-day weekend
approaching thousands are headed to the
lake but even with Lake Mead Rising
there's still some safety concerns 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthey takes a
dive into those problems
well it's a relatively calm day on Lake
Mead right now but these waters are
expected to fill with hundreds of more
boaters coming this Memorial Day weekend
and even with Rising water levels safety
concerns still linger both above and
below the surface the leaves are ending
a week-long boating trip I try to stay
away from everybody right before the
wave of new boaters and activities Gary
Lee says they bring they're playing
double two behind them and they were
crashing into each other so it's like it
looks pretty dangerous to me
if they're drinking while operating on
vessel Rangers like Alberto Flores will
be out in droves looking for drunk
drivers unsafe boat operations and
making sure everyone who's required to
wears one of these if they resist they
could potentials face uh fines and or
their their timing like me to to end at
that point
and in the most unlikely of places hoses
like this used for brush fires on the
shore and fueling mishaps on the water
little tiny islands that are kind of
cropping up what Lake Mead Recreation
Area superintendent Justin Pattinson
says is still a concern even as water is
three feet higher than this time last
year but a larger concern drowning he
says over 40 in the last six years here
the most recent a 44 year old man in
September wearing no life jacket and
they're quickly blown out further into
the lake if they don't have a life
jacket on those can result in
significant injuries sometimes and and
and even in water just up to your waist
the 4 Forest Service recommends
everybody wear a life vest though if on
a boat it's not required by federal law
unless you're 13 years of age and
younger reporting at Lake Mead Ryan
Matthey 8 news now Ryan thank you now
the park service has most pool toys not
allowed in the lake contribute to the
drownings that you heard about those
that are allowed must be approved by the
United States Coast Guard also five
launch ramps on the lake are now all
open